e e e e e e e e e e e e e e e x
ma belle ♪
- La vututututrée
de Karim Ouellet,
qui a touché le pudes chansons ,
s'est éteinte prématurément.
L'auteur-compositeur-interprète,
qui venait d'avoir 37 ans,vivivi
soir, à l'intérieur du studio
L'Unisson, dans le quartier
Saint-Roch, à Québec.
laisse la communauté
artistique sous le choc.
LOUIS BELLAVANCE, dir. program.
- Stupéfaction. C'est...
tétététété un choc ce matin,
comme pour tout le monde.
Et Karim
d'intégrer des influences
américaines un p
hip-hop, parce qu'il vient
beaucoup de ce côté-lmememememet
assumée, très, très vivant
des refrains incroyables.
♪ Rien ne sert de courir ♪
la grande complicité
qui s'était développée
durant la réalisation des
CLAUDE BÉGIN, réalisateur album"
c'est une grande...
grande tempête aujourd'hui.
Le Québe
puis je trouve qu'au-delà
de la tristesse, il y a
énormément d'amour qui ressort
de tout ça, puis on voit à ques.
- La soeur de Karim Ouellet,
la rappeuse Sarahmée,
au nom de sa famille par
le biais des réseaux sociaux.
Né à Dakar, au Sénégal,
Karim Ouellet a grandi au
Dès 2007, il se fait connaître
en collaborant avec plusieurs
artistes de la capitale.
Avec son second album,
intitulé "Fox", Karim Ouellet
et remporte plusieurs prix, donm
francophone de l'année en 2014.
à des événements d'envergure,
comme la fête du Canada,
et accompagne en tournéee.e.e.e.
Le premier ministre
François Legault a salué
à la musique québécoise.
Justin Trudeau a, pour sa partf
et avant-gardiste.
- Avec une bonne ligne mélodique
c'est le petit défi
nnnnnnnnnnnnnnnne...
- Le Bureau du coroner
tentera la cause du décès de l'.
La thèse criarararararararartée.